foreign
that if Infinity occurs your theory is
broken down your theory is not good
enough and you need a better Theory so
that is how have you heard it that if if
Infinity occurs in your theory it means
your model has gone beyond this domain
of validity when you say head to reach
infinity that's a fundamental mistake it
will always be expanding towards
Infinity but it will never reach
infinity that's the fundamental
distinction you won't ever get there
uh David respond to that that you you
you're bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger forever but you never reach it 50
not enough this is just a Prejudice and
in this now it's become a Prejudice
about what words we use the space-time
manifold either is infinite in time or
it's finite in time right and if it's
finite in time then it comes to an end
after a finite time and that means if
you are rejecting the infinite ones
you'd be rejecting a whole class of
cosmological theories for no physical
reason I'm not I'm not projecting models
which expand forever all I'm saying is
that they never reach that final state
it is always in the future
um
the space-time doesn't reach things it
is there it's a four-dimensional thing
yeah so so this is a deep underlying
just dispute I don't believe in a block
Universe I believe in a growing block
universe that space-time is expanding it
has the future boundary now it turns out
that NASA agree with me they think the
universe is 13.7 billion years old if it
is 13.7 billion years old it doesn't
stretch to Infinity that is its age it
will be bigger later it'll be bigger
later but it will never be Infinity as
old it will be getting over and over and
over a bit it'll never actually be
Infinity so I believe in evolving block
Universe not a block Universe which has
already reached Infinity that doesn't
make physical sense but let me put a
challenge to David what experiment would
prove to you that Infinity exists what's
what's the experiment
as I said we don't judge scientific
theories by what we can prove an
experiment can never prove any thing it
can only disprove at best and it can
explain and those are the two criteria
by which we need to judge science not by
whether we believe it's a block universe
or not a block Universe it's whether the
theory
of its being a block universe is a good
explanation of what we want to explain
in the world
there's a distinction here between some
mathematical physicists who have
theories of space time which produce a
block Universe for real working
cosmologists the people who analyze the
Planck data do not believe that they
assign a age to the universe which says
it it does not stretch to Infinity it is
moving towards him but they assign a age
to the universe at the present time
which is in fact contradiction to the
people who say we live in the black
universe
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV